they're going to remake the classic 1954
them and God I'm really excited welcome
to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
it was kind of the golden age of Cinema
when when you actually bought a ticket
for a movie you didn't just get one film
oh no you regularly got two there would
be the main theatrical release the big
movie of the week and then there would
be the B Movie now you gotta remember
this was back in a time when MGM and the
other Studios were making a film a week
this was your main form of entertainment
this is what you did on a Friday night
it was not sitting in front of the boob
tube watching whatever crap was on that
week or your soap operas it was going to
the cinema and Bam was just one of those
movies
that really kicked off a whole genre
we're still making monster movies today
that are based on the formula of this
1954 classic directed by Gordon Douglas
a couple of reasons why I love this
movie before I talk about the remake of
this plant and who's going to be doing
it I just want to just share this little
story with you
whenever I hear a car drive past that's
got um an alternator belt problem it
makes that lovely screeching noise
I think you guys can hear that is that
loud enough
and I will regularly go big ants and
nobody ever gets me nobody never nobody
ever wants his gun oh them not not ever
it's just not happen and it's tickled me
for years
[Music]
I as a kid watched these films and I
genuinely also believe that films like
them feels like it's with a giant spider
that freaked me out that right it might
have caused my Arachnophobia and films
like The Day the Earth Stood Still as
some of the greatest Cinema ever made
because they were properly original you
know we complained today about oh why
can't Hollywood do anything original why
can't they make something that's not
been done before why it's always going
to be a remake a reboot over there
this was when they were really
pioneering cinema this is when they were
genuinely doing something original when
the movie them came out in 1954 with the
giant animatronic ants eating people
where human courage challenges The Brute
Force the slicing Jaws the poison fangs
that guard the Subterranean Nest where
the Beast spawns its terrible progeny
the noise the soundtrack everything else
nobody had ever seen anything quite like
it tell you gentlemen science has agreed
that unless something is done and done
quickly man is the dominant species of
life on Earth
would be extinct within a year now that
is going to be a major problem for the
reboot and the Remake because this film
was genuinely iconic it's genuinely
original how do you do something new
based on something that was just so
classic well the director this being
given that monumentally epic task is
Michael geacino now this is a name you
might not know that well but it is
definitely a name you have seen on the
big screen many times it is mostly known
for his composition work he's a composer
he has actually won the Academy Award
for the music he composed for the movie
up he's done lots of other projects he's
won bafta's Golden Globe so on and so on
but also recently he directed werewolf
by night for Marvel Studios
[Music]
now for me that was one of the most
interesting things Marvel did all of
last year it was a very interesting I
would actually argue very classical Bee
Movie the whole style of the movie The
acting the cinematography everything was
done very much in the B Movie styling
[Music]
it was done very much on purpose and it
was done very very well
[Music]
the story was fascinating the obviously
based on the original Marvel comic with
a modern twist so could he do the same
for them that he did with wealth by
night well now he has already been
talking about this project and he's been
saying that this is a movie that he
comes back to over and over again in his
thoughts he has broken the movie down
into its summer Parts he's talked about
how maybe it was about immigration back
in the day that it was about them being
the unknown the other we may be
witnesses to a Biblical prophecy come
true and thus be destruction and
darkness come up in creation
and the beasts will reign over the Earth
and he then said though the two words
that put a little bit of fear in my
heart
fresh take so he wants to do a fresh
take on the original monster movie so
what the bloody hell that means we can
only be fearful but
let's be honest this is a film that is
God's 70 years old nearly why not give
it a try and it's something I'd love to
see with modern special effects Etc
from a pragmatic point of view though
giant ants if we get past the whole
biology exoskeleton they can't actually
survive past a certain size issue and
maybe I'm looking into it a bit too much
there but
they would be if they were scaled up
really really fast really really strong
and they would multiply like freaking
crazy so in the advert for the original
1954 movie they talked about how this
was the end of civilization it really
really would be in the advert they talk
about how mankind will be gone within 12
months
I think that might be ambitious I think
we might have less so let's all hope we
don't get eaten by giant ants anytime
soon but next time a car does drive past
you with a faulty alternator belt and
makes that glorious noise I suggest you
just look over your shoulder look around
the corner
ask the person nearest to you
have you seen any ants
just in case they are about to attack
please guys get in the comments tell me
what you think about this news that
they're going to be remaking this
classic 1954 horror movie I'd love to
know guys if you ever actually watched
the original if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification so you don't miss any
of our new videos also if you really
want to support the channel consider
hitting that join button as always
please stay safe I'll see you next time
[Music]